-Well, guys, I know it's been
hard to travel this summer.
Vacations and trips to see
family and friends
have been delayed or canceled,
but I just heard of a company
that will take you
on a different kind of vacation.
Check this out.
-Thank you very much.
Hello, there. I'm Chet Bevins,
travel agent,
sound bath conductor,
and the inventor
of the in-app purchase.
Now, I've put my years of
experience in travel, tech,
and wellness together to offer
you a brand-new opportunity.
So many of us have had to cancel
summer plans,
trips to see loved ones,
and vacations,
but now I'm inviting all of you
to go on a vacation
in your mind.
So pack your dream luggage,
leave instructions for the cat
sitter in your subconscious,
and come with me on one of
my new Imagination Vacation
packages.
Hyper-realistic, and I'm talking
hyper-realistic vacations
that you can take from the
comfort of your very own brain.
Let's take a little peek at
our tropical getaway package.
You arrive at your gorgeous
five-star hotel.
You're greeted with
a cold local drink
as you take in
the gorgeous surroundings.
The concierge welcomes you
with a smile and a customary
regional greeting.
And they take your card and your
credit card isn't going through.
Do you have another one?
And you're like, "No, I thought
I pre-paid."
And she's like, "Well, I just
need one for the incidentals."
And you're like, "Well, I don't
have another card."
And she's like,
"Okay, no problem.
There's an ATM at a gas station
30 miles from here.
It's accessible only by bus.
The 'bus' only comes once a day,
but we never know when."
Totally vacation, totally
imagination, totally realistic.
As real as you can imagine it.
And that's not all.
If tropical vacations
aren't your thing,
check out our family
amusement park package.
The lot, the music,
the cotton candy, the rides.
There you are,
with your smiling family,
in line for the big kid
roller coaster
and getting close to
the end of your wait.
You look down at your precious
children as their excitement --
and now they're punching
each other in the face.
Hey, this is what they wanted.
"You wanted to go on this ride,
and now you're punching
each other?
What do you want?"
Maybe taking to the slopes is
what your dreams are made of.
After a long day of skiing,
it's time to dip your sore,
aching muscles
into the Olympic-sized
heated salt of --
The pool's closed?
For a dog wedding?
What is that?
Just like in real life.
Plus, we offer add-ons
to any existing package,
including screaming kid
in first-class cabin,
"took the wrong suitcase
at the airport
and now you're wearing some
random guy's shorts all week,"
traveler's tummy,
and our most popular add-on --
fight with your spouse in Paris,
city of romance.
Your partner looks at you,
disappointment in their eyes.
"I thought you wanted to see
the Eiffel Tower," you say.
"I didn't say I wanted
to walk there," they say.
"I thought we were closer
than we were," you say.
"Well, learn how to read a map.
You always do this," they say.
So sign up today for Chet
Bevins' Imagination Vacations.
Your body's never gone on
a perfect vacation,
so why should your mind?
Chet speaking.